although Evy is with Doug and Carlos is
dating Jane we have seen so many signs
in The Descendants movies that these two
friends are going to end up together and
we can't fake it
okay keep watching and tell the end of
this video to see the big clue in Disney
merchandise that suggests these two vks
are destined to be together in the first
decent movie it's clear that Evie has a
crush on Carlos
you just have to notice the special way
she looks at him to realize it
check out her admiring gaze when Carlos
uses his tech wizardry to locate the
museum where the fairy godmothers wand
is being held her broad smile is so
telling Evie is also super excited to
see Carlos on the tour knee filled she
can't stop cheering and smiling when he
comes out to play and also when he
assists in the team's victory Ben's
coronation scene also includes two
moments when Evie looks at Carlos with
intent
first when they're sitting up on the
balcony with Jay Evie slow turn - Carlos
is so intense
then when Evie and Carlos are with Jay
and mal
downstairs at auradon Cathedral we see
the close connection between them again
the 4vk is all join hands as they agree
to choose to be good
Evie and Carlos stare at each other as
he makes his decision so what about the
signs that Carlos has a crush on Evie in
descendants - it's even more obvious
that they have a soft spot for each
other keep watching for some of the most
powerful scenes between them when Evie
and Carlos take bends at the aisle to
find mouths they teach him how to behave
like a VK and their song chilling like a
villain we see Carlos staring at Evie in
a super intense way as she shows Ben the
ropes
it looks like he's totally crushing on
her one of Evie and Carlos is most
noteworthy special moments takes place
during the Girl Talk scene this is when
the four main BK's returned from
rescuing then from the aisle
Evie and Carlos take the lead in giving
mal advice about her relationship with
Ben and their words reveal exactly why
Evie and Carlos are meant to be together
because they understand each other in a
way that no one else can Carlos talks
about them all being family and
them that they've been through a lot
together we're your family too we've
been through a lot together
Evy takes it further explaining that
we're always gonna be the kids from the
aisle those are their roots and they're
never going to be like anyone else I
tried to forget it I really tried but
those are our roots but that's okay
as Carlos adds they can't fake it that's
okay
and we can't fake it this explains why
Evy and Doug might not work out and why
Jane won't ever understand Carlos as
well as Evy does these two vks have an
unshakeable bond because of their shared
history and friendship it's Carlos his
final piece of advice that really
cements a 10 he tells mal if Ben doesn't
love the real her then he's not the one
and Evie responds by saying I like that
these two are so on the same wavelength
at the very end of the group's chat Evie
holds mal close and mouthed something to
Carlos they share an intense moment I
see mouths something back it's not
totally clear what the words are that
they're mouth into each other it might
be thank you and you're welcome or no
problem or it could be love you but it's
clear that they have deep feelings for
each other if I'd seen with umas pirate
gang in the second movie also shows us
how much the pair has got each other's
backs during the song it's going down
Evy holds out her hand to Carlos and
helps pull him across the docks
they then whisper to each other creating
the plan to use dudes talking ability
to trick umma into thinking the wand is
real to create the final diversion
carlos throws the package of purple
smoke to evey for her to release talk
about teamwork at the end of the movie
we get the biggest clue yet that Evy and
Carlos are crushing on each other it
happens during the you and me song at
the cotillion Evy reaches out her hand
to Carlos and he takes it the couple
head to their railing together to sing a
duet they have their arms around each
other and hold hands as they sing about
learning that together they can change
the world
Evy gives Carlos's hair ruffle so
adorable we're finishing up with the big
clue Disney has given us that even
Carlos could end up together at the end
of descendants three way back at the
beginning of the franchise Disney
released figures of the main characters
this included a couple of packs that
contained two dolls one was mal and Ben
that totally makes sense but did you
know that the other twin pack of dolls
was Evie and Carlos if that isn't a
massive hints that these two sweethearts
are destined to end up together at the
end of the franchise
just like mal and Ben and we don't know
what is are you shipping
Evie and Carlos or do you think they're
better off as friends and do you think
there could be a couple swap in
descendants three with Doug and Jane
ending up together let us know in the
comments below give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to our channel
for more great videos like this one
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]